Google engineering director and futurist
Ray Kurzweil believes we are close to
living in immortality and he's working
on it on his own body right the second
he takes a hundred fifty vitamins a day
and he's sort of broken down how he
believes he is going to live forever and
he talks about three bridges so we're
going to break him down let's look at
the first one so bridge one is to stay
as healthy as possible with diet and
exercise and current medicine okay that
seems pretty standard nothing he's not
reinventing the wheel right right
exercise okay pretty good bridge to is
the biotechnology revolution where we
can reprogram biology away from disease
max I know this is your department haha
so can you break down bridge to for us a
little bit yeah Bridge to um you know
we're sort of at the cost know where a
lot of sort of gene therapies the price
is coming down you know like you can
already have your entire genome decoded
you can go to 23 Emmy com so aside from
just fitness and nutrition and
supplementation we'll get to a point
where technology can actually you know
inter can actually intervene and cure a
lot of the ills that people are faced
with from diseases to aging itself I
think nanotechnology is involved in
bridge three is that yes let's talk
about bridge three bridge three is to go
beyond biology to the nano technology
revolution at that point we can have
little robots called nanobots that
augment your immune system we can create
an immune system that recognizes all
disease and if a new disease emerged it
could be reprogrammed to deal with new
pathogens every time I think in nanobots
it reminds me of did you guys ever play
metal gear solid on playstation or a
Nintendo or something it was all about
nano bots didn't fire that sounds great
great game all right well played that
but he obviously did so literally robots
are going to be inside of us they're not
going to look like robots as we think of
them today they're going to be
infinitely smaller than our iphones
infinitely smarter and cheaper so you'll
actually that I mean they could in
effect take on like a fluid like nature
and you
inject ourselves with them and you have
got little nanobots cooker you know
coursing through your veins repairing
damage at a genetic level right I think
it's really excited okay so I don't
wanna get too into the science of
because I think it's going to go over
everybody's head but not your head but
probably probably are I've already lost
so but so is this the most natural and
human thing possible that we're using
science to extend life or is this the
reverse of that because dying is a part
of life well that's a really big
question a debate that's a good night
take that I mean for me it's it's a
pretty exciting thing when you basically
talk about how you can reboot your whole
system and change you know he talks
about changing the operating system and
reprogramming it where you can go in and
turn genes on and off I think that's how
it works and so I mean you know if
you've lost loved ones from something
that's potentially preventable by doing
this I'm I'm down for it ya know yeah i
mean i think that people sort of when
they hear him you know say that he wants
to be immortal and cure aging that's
when people get weirded out i think that
that's an amazing thing to aim for you
know like who wants to age you know we
sort of think of death as this thing
that's in the distant future but like
getting there requires like your joints
not working as well as i used to we're
seeing your loved ones die you know and
i think that that's all horrible and i
love where his heart is exact to sort of
put it into that but is there something
about the human experience that then we
could potentially be losing if you can
live forever i mean we do have a circle
of life that has worked for you know
that we call it life because it's
limited I don't think so you know like
we Allen says life gives meaning to life
not death you know but I also do you
know it does beg the question about who
you know gets access to these things so
that eventually it just becomes kind of
you know rich people or privileged
people or white people probably yeah I
think about technology is that it lifts
all boats you know like I think that you
know at the beginning some of these
technologies usually a reserved for you
know the wealthier but I mean I was
talking about 23 and me at first when
that service launched it was a thousand
dollars to decode your DNA and now it's
either ninety nine dollars or 100
million it's like wildly cheap right
this wash them wearing right now is
tracking all kinds of biometrics and
it's two hundred dollars it's like about
what do we need to know what I'm at
Wrigley it's a tracking our metrics
occur biomed mine it's got my heart rate
is tracking perspiration body too
it's very cool yes so cheap yeah it's
like what does that tell you though that
just sort of as a general I'm this
healthier or something well it's part of
what people call the quantified self
movement the more you can know about
your biology the better so that you can
reprogram it you can look out for
certain things and maybe your parents
had that you don't want to catch you
know to me there was a when I was
reading about what curse while I was
talking about this he said that there's
you know a very simple thing that we can
do right away which is almost program
our genes to process fat to process how
we you know you know get fat basically
so there's a there's a you know he talks
about in the very close future where
you'll just be able to take a pill that
basically helps you metabolize so you
can eat McDonald's and crap but then
just metabolize it differently because
the way we've evolved we have this fat
insulin receptor gene which hold on to
everything that we eat because there
might be a fast coming up there might be
a long period where we can't find any
food but that gene today is obsolete
there's food everywhere right so why
wouldn't you want to like suppress that
gene so that you can eat whatever you
want your old outdated biological
software doesn't want to just hold on to
it yeah yeah ok so I'm a big sci-fi guy
and we've talked about this on the show
many times I'm a firm believer that the
robots will come and destroy us one day
or enslave us or some kind of Terminator
style stuff so if we start putting these
robots even though they're not robots as
we think of them in our bodies I mean
ultimately I see a lot of there's a big
window for a lot of bad stuff to have me
why can't they just turn on us and all
that whole thing ray actually always
uses the metaphor fire fire can either
burn you or cook your food you know it's
really up to humans to to dictate the
course of where technology takes us as a
species but I'm optimistic like you are
and like you are I'm sure and you know I
think that like we'll make the best of
it will use it to cure aging it's like
it's when it gets complicated when when
business you know interferes you know
and you know a profit modem is is what's
pursued rather than innovation for
innovation itself but uh they do talk
about these two different ideas of
singularity one where you know we sort
of blend in and become you know half
half man half robot it and the other one
where there is a moment where since
robots are controls as artificial
intelligence shows up and is controlling
then what what need do they have for
humans anymore on the planet if we're
just sort of looking at us like we're
another part of the sickness or disease
that I can't start thinking about right
collapse leave about nine cuz wouldn't
we just be like some you know variable
that can't be controlled we would be a
virus some robots don't need us and then
that's that is that what that video game
was about or digital sue heard of that
was the Terminator mostly but yeah well
I guess we've given you a lot to think
about here my water balloon vines are
totally blown hey guys don't forget the
Reuben reports brought to you by Koopa
com they've got up to 75 percent off pet
treats toys and more and if you use code
are are you get another twenty percent
off that's a lot off there is a link in
the description right down below code
are are twenty percent off make your pet
happy